one of the things they've been saying to
about the wall is that they want to keep
drugs from coming in illegal drugs but
from this El Chapo trial we're learning
how the biggest drug dealer in Mexico
got his drugs in they didn't use they
didn't get it through the wall they
brought it in through mostly boats yeah
it's usually not just mules you know
individuals carton it across some you
know broken part of the of the border
they brought it on through cars and
hidden compartments they brought it in
through boats I mean they're they're you
know they basically have some people
spilling the beans as to how the exact
operation was was functional yeah that
didn't seem to involve people carrying
it over the border on backpacks and now
now one of Guzman El Chapo's lieutenants
is as cooperating witness yeah and he's
now he's now claiming that the former
president in Mexico Pina Neto was given
a hundred million dollars at the outset
of his term I think it was 2012 when he
started as president so when he was
president-elect he'd already won but he
was waiting to take the seat according
to this this Colombian trafficker who
was working with Guzman with Chapel Pena
Neto reached out to him possibly through
his campaign manager however the story
goes my friend yeah and he asked for 250
million hmm and Chapel you know came
back with a negotiated position and says
100 million which was then according to
this again the guys at Colombian
trafficker
you know how legitimate is he you know
then you know the money was transferred
to pinion Neto and you know opinion
Eddowes people are saying that's
ridiculous look we were the ones who
tracked him down you know even though he
escaped you know 48 times or whatever he
escaped and but there's always been this
this talk about how Chapo's arrests were
orchestrated right but and that so that
they the military the police were
involved somehow that there was a
coordinated effort and there's always
been that underlying rumor you know is
it possible anything's possible but if
he did get a hundred million dollars you
would think El Chapo would be free Jesus
Christ 100 million dollars get you free
right right yeah I know and you would
yeah you would assume that you know
what's the upside for Chapel to to not
talk about it now right you know but you
know who knows it's it's a president to
mean where is he it doesn't have tax
returns they could look at they've moved
it just moved it offshore immediately
apparently was according to this witness
or to this cooperating a witness he the
money was delivered this may be the the
part of the story that doesn't hold up
it was delivered to his campaign plane
or something and this campaign manager
you know took control of it and then
they whisked it away and whether you
know a hole in the ground somewhere yeah
takes out a little at a time